le conseil municipal des enfants de
guyancourt fête ses 30 ans pour
l'occasion une exposition retrace
l'histoire de ce conseil et ses
réalisations
il a été créé en 1990 pour inciter les
jeunes à être impliqué dans la vie de la
commune il y a trente cinq enfants qui
sont élus sur le même modèle que le
conseil municipal de la ville de bus en
cours et ils ont entre 8 et 13 ans un
mandat dure deux ans depuis sa création
plus de 600 enfants sans passer par ce
conseil municipal
écoutez c'est une excellente école pour
tous ces jeunes on sait qu'on est dans
une période où effectivement il faut
rapprocher les habitants de la vie
municipale de l'implication public et
travailler avec dès le plus jeune âge
est important c'est aussi des porte
paroles très fort vis-à-vis de leur père
évidemment mais aussi vis-à-vis de leurs
parents c'est important parce que les
parents sont aussi derrière
éduquons implique aussi les parents une
fois élus les enfants viennent
bénévolement ans mercredi après midi sur
deux pour travailler ensemble sur des
sujets qui les intéressent même des
thématiques qui reste le développement
durable la sécurité routière les loisirs
et la prévention c'est vraiment autour
des depuis 30 ans les thématiques qu'on
retrouve et qu'on du coup on voit dans
l'exposition au travers des projets des
conseillers parmi les projets une carte
de guyancourt vue par les enfants
aujourd'hui cette carte est demandée par
des enseignants elle a d'ailleurs été
primée par l'association nationale des
conseils d'enfants et de jeunes en
france